good morning
Millennials welcome back to the chosen
happy
Thurday that feels like a real Thursday
you know what I'm saying you know that's
not been my experience oh my God just
once like just a great like for the sake
of agreeing like nobody cares my excuse
me like it's not that deep like yeah it
feels like a Thursday oh cuz it is like
it's not that deep okay feels like a
Thursday yes I'm so glad you agree yeah
I couldn't have said it better myself
you look gorgeous we're both wearing
just kind of like comfy cozy energy
today we're giving gy I'm wear sometimes
there's nothing cuter than a gray like
zipup hoodie I stole this from Olivia
and she's not getting it back sorry gray
is tough for me um now that I've
discovered that I think I'm a
winter okay so like I don't know is gray
a winter or a spring definitely not a
spring it might be an Autumn you should
just get your colors done I know for the
amount that I talk about it yeah I think
I have some an email in my inbox I need
to uh read it and see if the person's in
Florida because then we should do it
while you're here patreon oh speaking of
patreon probably up today I started the
editing process last night I vlogged my
whole evening last night which was my
book club with my private Chef catered
affir it was so good the book club like
everyone's talking about it everyone
said it was like one of our best
meetings yet the food was so good the
conversation was so good it's really a
great book club book everyone liked the
book had a lot of very strong critiques
of the book um did you hear about Kitty
car was the name of the book really just
kind of like a textbook perfect evening
and a great book club book you would say
yeah I I have a I'm like very frustrated
it was the author's first like debut
novel which is so major I almost wish
she had waited to tell the story like
she had a little bit more experience
under her belt CU she tried to do a
little too much and by the end of the
book it's like she ruined the magic she
had created in the
middle and it was on its way to being
like one of my favorite books ever wow
and I like was so frustrated with it
like I kind of hate it now it's it's
very confusing and everybody was feeling
the same way got it interesting what are
you guys reading next uh we'll find out
today very cool well redheads speaking
of book clubs we are reading actually
this is kind of exciting big redheads
news oh my God hold your G your loins
we're reading the Frozen River by Ariel
Lan who wrote code Nam Helen okay which
makes this our first time that we're
doing an author twice on the redheads
and she's our I didn't I didn't think it
would be her but it's her yeah but like
who else would it be you know like it
could be you know one of the classics
Sally Hepworth yeah Jessica null yeah
yeah Jess Hannah yeah yeah yeah but it's
Ariel Lan which I love that for her I
loved code name Helen so I'm really
excited for Frozen River it's a
historical fiction book it's like based
on a true story which I love we haven't
done his charcoal fiction at the
redheads in a while and in my personal
life I've kind of been slipping
on my historical fiction we caught we
caught Jack slipping you caught me
slipping so I kind of need to get back
into the history books and I think
that's a good way to dip my toe into the
Frozen River I am so excited to see you
in just a mere you know two days hours
technically hours at this point I'm
giddy with excitement I can't wait to
see my
family and it's just it's the end of the
week I'm seeing my family it's the Super
Bowl I have my health no it's I
everything's kind of coming up
excitement
joyousness positivity fun fun
fun I'm going to leave it at
there I couldn't agree more so important
like when you're
at you know the summit of something is
that the right use of the word is the
summit at the top or the way up like
it's like you're at the edge of the
cliff like you're like there you're
there okay so okay I guess maybe no
maybe that wouldn't be all all I'm
trying to say is like I feel like a huge
part of like maintaining a healthy
mindset in life is like to acknowledge
like exciting things coming and like I
in this moment I just want to be very
present saying I'm so excited for what's
to come for me in the in the next couple
of days the Summit is the highest point
okay so I guess I'm like about to to
reach the summit and I'm sitting here
like taking a moment of gratitude yeah
and I think the way to the sum the on
the way to The Summit in is in some ways
better than the summit I would agree
because you have what to look forward to
that's really the message of the climb
yeah so once again the
climb it's always relevant once again
everything comes back to the climb well
that's the truth I've been in such a
Miley Renaissance since the Grammys I've
been listening to Endless Summer
vacation because I was like I want more
of of this girl of that energy what I
didn't realize is the song used to be
young which is one of my favorite songs
of last year we talked about it on the
patreon of 2023 recap is from that album
yeah I thought it was like a new single
she was doing new things so I'm like
okay so there are two songs that are
kind of like life-changing for me from
that album I need to listen to the whole
album and I I only got into four songs
before I was forced to play Happy song
Oh my book club was talking about Happy
song is it really life- saving for them
as well
some of the mothers in book club they
were familiar with the Happy song and
then some of the newer mothers hadn't
heard of it yet and this was like kind
of the passing of the torch yeah to
those new mother there's someone out
here there who needs to hear this if you
have a fussy baby there's a song by
imagin Heap who is a great talent she
sings good night and go other Bops but
she wrote a song for children called the
Happy song that is like melodically and
chemically written to cheer up your baby
give it a try it's like designed to ease
the mind yeah give it a try next time
baby is like fussy and it's not cuz
they're hungry or they're pooped or need
a burp or this or that like try the
Happy song it works for us not all the
time but enough of the time it worked
magically oh my God Jackie I forgot to I
mean I did tell you this but I need to
talk about on the podcast I'm going
insanely viral I
heard okay so I was looking through my
Tik Tok drafts like just to see like
things I haven't posted and I forgot
that I had made this Tik toac while we
were on our family vacation and I posted
it it was just this funny moment where
we all got up from the dinner table and
we realized that our sister Margot had
eaten her dinner off of the charger not
the actual plate and it was like this
funny stupid thing I literally went to
bed and I was like oh my God is that
700,000 views I woke up this morning now
6.3 million Claudia the universal No
Deal Tick Tock Kur fuffle is great for
you no music okay for a for a second I
was like are you speaking English the
universal No Deal Kur fuffle like now it
makes sense so no you're totally right
now the comments are really split people
being like you are just like Rich this
is such like a privilege first world
problem even though like a charger like
you can literally get like at the dollar
store for 65 cents um like if you never
been to a wedding um and then most
people also being like what is a charger
people like don't know what Chargers are
I learned about Chargers late in life
too I think a lot of people learn about
Chargers when they get married yeah when
did I learn about Chargers I don't even
think it was when I got married cuz I
didn't register for Chargers but I no
not not registered like Decor at your
actual wedding that's I think really
when I learned what a charger was yeah
so it's like a plate that's just
decorative it's a it's like a place mat
made out of plate but it's like really
not made out of plate it's not food safe
No but it's it's very akin to a plate
it's of the plate elk oh it looks like a
plate but I'm talking about material
wise sometimes they're like made of wood
they're not really safe to eat off of no
no but you could get confused it looks
like a plate and unless it's especially
when it's
like whatever the matal it's the same
shape the shape but even the material of
the one that she ate off
of was a little confusing except for the
fact that like it was a charger yeah so
I'm just like kind of going majorly
viral like all these you know
like uh like BuzzFeed type like accounts
being like we'd love to share your video
please submit content and consent an
approval here I'm like no [__] you
think you're taking away My Views eat my
ass I'm not think it's going to like
help raise your Rising tide ra raise
your
sh do you think I should do it no no no
I want all the clicks you want all the
clicks but you
don't like you might need the
distribution to get more clicks we know
we we'll get there maybe I'll sign a
distribution deal later on but right now
I'm just like kind of enjoying my moment
for sure but don't o don't overplay your
hand so true and you only have like
minutes
left before
should I sign it now what was the
Publications anything legit yeah like
lad Bible you know like all those big
Facebook page type of that's really how
you get your name out there should I do
it I think lad Bible you could do I
don't know maybe yeah like maybe then we
could do like I don't know the toast UK
tour or something I think it should be
publication dependent not just like all
Publications can have of the video but
like worthy ones yeah yeah I feel like
bartool sports is like about to knock on
my door like they love to do would you
let
them that's how you go viral because
then
Jackie what have they said about Israel
that's my litus test like if if when if
when Annie Lennox wanted to repost my
video you know what I would say tury
says no that's what I would say no bar
stool is marked safe Dave is good yeah
yeah I would I would give it to bar I
have to check what what lad Bible's been
saying about the war in Israel when Baro
like then distributes then so many more
people see it and that's how you end up
on GMA Today's Show oh my God you by
what if I have to postpone my trip to
you seeu because they want me on the
Today's Show but what if what if they
want
Margot you're that's interesting you're
not in the
video I sound like Madison beer but like
I supposed to be in the
video no I am in the video you just
can't see the star so by the way so
Shapiro he's like in the reflection of
the window like cracking up at Marg what
if they want Margo and Shapiro on
GMA oh then I won't sign over any rights
and everybody can stay less famous than
I just when I think about examples that
are akin to what you're experiencing
it's the person on camera who Hoda wants
to talk to of course of course not the
sister who posted it unless sometimes
the person could bring their sister and
maybe she would bring you maybe she
would bring me maybe I just won't
forward the email that I get from the
Today's Show producers asking to be
connected with my sister also you and
Mar look alike you could impersonate her
so
true okay you're going to steal the
shine yeah or maybe I'll just let this
thing die you know no one else if I
can't get famous no one else can not
Rising Tides raise all shes for the
Sisters no no no not since you're dis
for from your family yeah oh and that's
the other element like I am Aaron Rogers
so no yeah cut it that's a wrap you
don't even have her
email exactly I couldn't forward it to
her if I wanted to sorry Oda we by the
way have an amazing show today because
we have the stories and and tell me
about them how are they like about them
there's a couple that feel like that
just tickled my fancy you know what I
mean and not because they're about Royal
Caribbean or the royal family I think
it's just like things that say Royal no
don't say that I'm going look into
this and then there's also the obvious
you know what you've may be seen in the
headlines I don't know what I've seen in
the headlines but what I I do know is
that with our new schedule today we also
have dear toasters we have some very
interesting sort of different ones you
know I love different we have a a a
write in about standup comedy we have a
story about stand-up comedy wait also
this next thing has nothing to do with
standup comedy I just remember that I
wanted to say it so guess why I spoke to
yesterday
TKS well I did yes but that's not what I
was gonna say um I spoke to my trainer
Hillary she listens to the toast and
she's G she's gonna get us Into 5K shape
she has like a whole plan she found us a
running coach like we're done we're good
we're done we're done I I'll be I'll be
able to like trade in person but she's
going to make a plan like for all of us
okay make a plan stay alert bring a
snack yeah stop drop and roll love that
okay great yeah also I think what I've
surmised is that maybe the 5K doesn't
have a location because they're like not
serious about about it and I think like
maybe we took it really
seriously oh my God not me getting a
running coach and this whole thing's a
joke that's what I was like getting from
the comments like by the way I think
they just like
say oh my God they just like say stuff
and they're not g like doing it there's
no
5K oh my God Jackie we named our episode
title about the 5K and there isn't even
a
I don't know that there isn't a 5k oh no
Jackie Jackie I was talking about at my
book club I was like I was like I think
Joe Rogan's going to come Jackie there
is no
5K there's no 5K there ever was a 5K and
that's why we wer invited and that's why
yeah that's why he can't tell us the
location oh
Jackie there is no
5K
no that's not confirmed but it's kind of
the the vibe I'm sensing but I got a
running coach maybe we do a toast
5K G no like I would never choose to do
it you know yeah and I was only doing it
I was only doing it for like the Thirsty
element that I would get to meet other
more famous successful people that like
who could prop me up and give me
attention and like followers and stuff
like let's be real I don't want a 5K for
fun yeah I had a goal in mind
charity no sorry like I'll just
donate I'll write a check
awareness I'll post on
Instagram so we'll we'll stay tuned I
mean you never know they could decide to
take it seriously but I'm just feeling
like serious by wait wait no now that
I'm thinking about it like Bert never
answered my DM like after he like I was
like oh
like we never connected like it was just
a story cuz there was nothing to connect
over cuz there's no
5K cool cool cool yeah there is no 5K
okay cool cool that's so awesome me
thinks and like this was just like this
little joke on their podcast that like
and they didn't even mean to but like an
unintended consequence of this like
funny joke from their podcast was like
these two enormous losers showing how
desperate and thirsty they are okay but
I just want to say this all started
because jelly roll said he was running a
5k oh I forgot jelly R was going to be
there yeah and so People magazine was
fooled too because that's where I saw it
but they are
fools so I don't know why I'm looping
myself in with them I like how like
we're yeah yeah we're not fools we
didn't fall for
it you just can't believe everything you
read on the internet I guess it's just
so crazy when you like find out piece of
information that like just re jiggers
the way you look at the world you know
and it like and it all makes sense I
have
like and why I really relate to this one
particular taylori lyric like in this
moment I've never been a natural all I
do is try try try like I am like
genuinely like at my core like a
desperate person like I don't I don't
really have any need to be like I have a
very full life I'm very successful thank
God knockwood like and this desperation
like this deeply uncool thing about me I
can't sort of shake and now I've just
been exposed by for for who I truly am
maybe exposing it and showing it to the
light is a way to kill it you know some
light
kills right I'm kind of like Edward
you're
Edward wow okay so that sort of shook
the foundation on which I walk yeah but
you should still train for the 5K with
your running coach I don't know about
that let's get into the stories because
as tury stated we have a lot to do today
and that's not waste time best to make
hastee without further Ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by current
old school banking just isn't working
anymore they ding you with ridiculous
fees play games with your money and they
want you to get into debt so stop
banking old and get current the future
of banking so current is banking and
credit building together they make it
super easy to get paid as soon as
possible build credit safely and save
more all done in one app managing your
money is hard current can make it easy
you set up direct deposits to get the
most out of current you can get paid up
to 2 days faster you can qualify for fee
free overdraft overdraft up to $200 for
when you spend more than you've got and
you can get their awesome looking build
card that's nothing that's like nothing
else out there you can build credit
safely using your own money so you don't
pile on debt there are no credit checks
so anyone can start building credit
right now with current and quite
possibly the best part about current is
that there's no annual or minimum
imbalance fees let me say that one more
time
in my opinion the best part about
current there are no annual or minimum
balance fees so what are you waiting for
girly get current the future of banking
go to current waiting for current.com
toast or download the app that's c r
nt.com toast terms to apply current is a
financial technology company not a bank
banking services provided by choice
financial group member FDIC and cross
river bank member FDIC for full terms
and conditions visit current.com
or call 888
85117 to for more information today's
episode is also brought to you by
Squarespace we love Squarespace the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place all on yet own
terms so whatever your reason for
starting a website U might be or wanting
to like rejigger your websites
Squarespace is such a great asset it's
pretty idiot proof and very user
friendly so whether you're not super
technologically advanced or a lot of
people I know like do um like work IRL
but they want websites for a portfolio
whether you're a photographer a graphic
designer an artist so there's a million
different reasons a million different
templates available on Squarespace to
Showcase your work whatever your work is
obviously if you work in e-commerce you
have a side hustle some sort of business
where you sell things online Squarespace
is amazing for getting all your orders
your inventory and um shoppable
experiences done you can sell custom
merch you can create an online store you
can Showcase Video collections you can
send out email campaigns they also offer
great analytics so you can use the
insights to grow your business learn
where your site visits and sales are
coming from Analyze which channels are
most
effective and um if you're a blogger
which you know I feel like if you're a
blogger like listening to the toast is a
full-time like part of the job they have
great blogging tools as well so go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain by using Code toast again head to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain using Code toast today's episode
is also brought to you by draftking
Sportsbook looking for a super offer for
Super Bowl 58 draftking Sportsbook has
got you covered new customers can bet on
the big game and turn five bucks into
200 instantly in bonus bets DraftKings
is such a great app to have on your
phone at all times obviously I feel like
we're all so sporty these days we're
obviously like a huge Sports podcast
where influential voices in sports and
draftking Sportsbook is so much fun
download the draftking Sportsbook app
now use code toast new customers can bet
five bucks to get 200 instantly in bonus
bets only on draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of Super
Bowl 58 with code toast the crown is
yours gambling problem visit 1800
Gambler or in West Virginia visit www.1
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
hopen or text Hope n46
7369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
8887895118
varies by jurisdiction voided Ontario
bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance see
dk.com
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
again our draftking Sportsbook code is
toast t o a s t thank you you're welcome
our first story a little comedy drama
Pete Davidson ditches a radio City
warm-up gig for Matt r at the last
minute wait what Matt R is performing a
three night stand at Radio City Musical
okay on my way here I passed like a
billboard to those Billboards that get
like put on construction sites yeah and
it was like congrats Matt R six sold out
shows so two shows a night for three
nights I was that's huge huge yeah and
Pete Davidson had agreed to open for him
warm up the crowd but they're they're
friends okay according to Radio City
insiders he backed out just 2 hours
before Showtime backstage sources at the
Rockefeller Center institution say that
Matt R's team had to scramble to find a
backup and eventually got someone lined
up with a matter of within a matter of
minutes before the curtain went up
according to a social media post from
the show uh John Campanelli ended up
filling in for Davidson
yeah I mean I don't think like finding
someone new would have been a problem
like any comic would be honored to to do
it but um if they sold the tickets being
like with special guest Pete Davidson
you know it's kind of a let down oh did
they I don't know if they I know but I'm
sure he was like really excited it's his
big night and the crowd would be so
hyped for Pete his friend is coming
through for him and then for two hours
before for Pete to cancel that's a
little I also think it's like crazy that
that Matt R got Pete Davidson to do
something for him like I don't know why
I think that's crazy I feel like Pete
Davidson I would have said like has good
friends and is a good friend cuz he's
always like they're always showing up
for him I feel like he has good
friendships but this isn't what a friend
does and of course like because Matt R
is kind of r with Scandal right now it
you your first thought is like is he
disassociating from Matt but I don't
think that's what it is I'm sure just
something came up Comics don't do that
Comics aren't losers who are like oh
there's a little bit of like backlash on
Tik Tok I should stay away like don't
give a [__] I don't think it has to do
with that either I also think yes Pete
has like a lot of friends but I also
think it's like the nature of like
comedy like everybody just like supports
one another and you need your friends in
that business or shall I say in this
business oh right in our business in our
business as comedians who run 5Ks who
are top of the charts comedians we need
friends luckily tury and I have each
other that's why we don't know anyone
else we no we have Burt and Tom until
further notice and you have
Tanks i i will always have
tanks which you have a lot of friends
not in the comedy space but in the
influencer space like we're friendly
influencers a lot of because you want to
know what it is like most comedy
podcasters come from the comedy world we
are comedy podcasters who weirdly came
from the influencer world yeah so we're
just different in that way and that's
why we're not like other shows and we're
probably better than everyone else if I
had to guess yeah sounds right speaking
of Comedy news something that wasn't a
story but I find to be newsworthy is
Gillis hosting SNL and I've been meaning
to talk about it I'm so glad you brought
that up because I saw it and I sent it
to you and I was shook because for
anyone who doesn't understand why it's a
big deal the first time I had ever heard
of Shane Gillis was many years ago when
he was announced as one of the new SNL
cast members and obviously for any comic
that's like the job of the century and
it's like the biggest deal then they had
announced that he was the uh one of the
new cast members of course you know the
internet did their thing found some old
clips of him saying some unsavory things
on a podcast specifically using a slur
and he was immediately you know the
offer was withdrawn and I think for like
any comic who you know gets to SNL I
don't know if there's anything worse
like I don't like I think what happened
to Shan Gillis is like so many people's
worse nightmare yeah it was to reach the
summit to reach the summit and then fall
down and then have it taken away and
what was so interesting about what
happened to Shane Gillis is that he kind
of took you know this lemon and made it
into lemonade and his career really blew
up after that he just like pounded the
pavement podcast podcast podcast he put
his he produced his own comedy special
put it out for free on YouTube it blew
up so much so that the next time he
recorded a special Netflix bought it and
it was like the number one special a few
months ago it was really popular yeah um
and he kind of made himself someone
who's like a little too famous to even
be a cast member on SNL he's kind of
someone who's you know the guest host on
SNL and they did it which I think is so
crazy like I don't know if I was Shane
Gillis would I be like butt hurt and
like bitter and not not accept I don't
know not for host to come back in that
way like if they had asked him to be a
cast member now I'm sure he would be
like oh you can go [__] yourself no and
he W makes he has a huge podcast he's
like below us sometimes but I sometimes
above us yeah yeah he's makes he was
doing that podcast before he even got
the first SNL job like everything that
he's doing now is what he was doing
before the first SNL job and that's why
he got the job and then he was taken
away from him and then he's Contin to
just like do Shane do his podcast do his
comedy and as we say the cream Rises and
now he will be hosting SNL which is
completely full circle and a really
crazy thing and I absolutely have to
watch his monologue just to see how this
is like to me this is historic like I I
need to see how they're going to address
it like and they're they're going to I
mean how could they not it's really the
elephant in the room but also it's so
interesting I think that when he was if
you watch his special and I've seen a
lot of Clips I think I watch the special
but I also see Clips he does like an
insan funny and good Trump impression
and I think that's why he was booked to
begin with for that impression because
if you think of who they've had play him
in the last few years after Alec Baldwin
or even maybe Al B included it's like
not great and no and the guy who they
currently have for Trump isn't a cast
member he just is the Trump guy he comes
in to do Trump but he's like not even a
good one agreed uh I'm sure they'll
utilize that I think they'll have him do
that impression but I that's why he
initially got the job it would make
sense cuz when you audition for SNL you
like audition with Impressions yeah no
and when I read Keenan's book not always
you know be bringing up Keenan it is
very impressions-based um it's like very
it's like old school like sketch comedy
it's not characters a lot of people who
I think try out for SNL maybe even get
on SNL like aren't like standup Comics
they do this sort of like improv they're
from like those improv groups so um shis
is very much like a multi-talented comic
because he does the Impressions but he
also writes like really good standup um
I'm fascinated by this and of course
people are like up in arms on the
internet being like you know he's not
sorry but I think this is like such an
interesting life cycle of a cancellation
and and we haven't seen it before this
to me this is set a precedent and I'm
beyond interested I also just think it's
like kind of crazy like to have let him
go like SNL was making a statement like
they were they were Mak which was very
uncom the comedy world like they don't
do that you know so it was very sort of
out of character and bizarre but of
course like when the mob comes like you
just Buckle like that's what people do
so the fact that they did cancel was
such like a strong
move and booking him is like a strong
move in the total opposite direction I I
find it very confusing yeah we'll see
how it plays
out and what sort of message they're
going to send and what they're going to
say about it I'm like I will be tuning
in maybe perhaps even live like that's
how interested I am see the musical
guest is 21 Savage
great great February 24th see you there
oh it's not this weekend no oh who on
God's green didly Del Earth knows where
I'm going to be on February 24th what is
this weekend let's see I don't think
there is SNL this week because it's also
the Super Bowl right yeah there is none
and they just like kind of make up their
own schedule I kind of love like and
respect that you know yeah like maybe
we'll do a show maybe we won't maybe
it'll be R they're just like always
keeping us on our toes yeah yeah cuz
we're just waiting with baited
breath are you ready for our next
story yes some really lovely news 40
Mega stars have come together for one
magnificent image on British Vogue as
they say A Farewell to Edward enfl the
editor-in chief of British Vogue so who
I didn't even know was leaving he's
leaving the cover of his final magazine
is 40 huge Stars one class picture they
all and they're like his girlies like
they're not random they all had like
been on the cover at one point in his
career they all signify like the past
the present and the future for him uh
they all came to New York on the same
day for a photo shoot and these are some
of like the biggest stars ever it's and
you know what it's giving it's giving
Jenna rink yes 13 Going on 30 like the
graduation prom scene when they all are
like in the park and there's leaves and
it's like the best scene on television
history it is but those were like
regular dular no and by the way I'm sure
like the vibe on this set was so toxic
and like rude they were like eating
cupcakes in Jenna rink's version and
there was like you know snow in the air
this one was probably just like a
different kind of snow the story they're
telling is like it was just such a
beautiful harmonious day so many I think
it was like a mega Factory of getting
all the girls ready in styled
and everyone comes with teams I think
there were probably so many people there
they shot it at like a warehouse in the
city but the final image is beautiful I
mean read me some of the names I mean I
saw it but uh Naomi Campbell Ka Gerber
and Cindy
Crawford oh I didn't put that together
because they weren't seated next to each
other there are a couple like
interesting Dynamics where it's like
placements I wonder how these two got
along uh Cara delvine Miley Cyrus
Victoria Beckham
Oprah uh Serena Williams Ana Taylor Joy
Carly Claus there were some like major
randoms in there Jamil Jam Jamila Jam
Ariana deos yeah like really random um
yeah there were a couple randoms I'm
sure they like mean something to Edward
Beckham yeah I said her love her Sor
Queen I can't
for oh I actually just met Amber vetta
nice lady and very gorgeous in person um
what I wanted to say before I like had
to be annoying and name drop and I
forgot what I was going to say shall I
continue you know British Vogue like is
so all the all the Vogues but like
British Vogue is really I feel
highlights like how much like better
American Vogue could be doing I feel
like American Vogue like never does
anything iconic they're always like
getting in trouble these days yeah no
always or other it's like Joe Koy and
then Trevor Noah it's like it shouldn't
be so hard here you have someone who
shows you how you could do your job no
and it's literally Vogue like you better
no and they act like oh we you know it's
hard to get a great cover and to to be
on the pulse but like British folk is
always showing it up I remembered what I
was going to say have you been seeing
the like pre-commercial Super Bowl
commercials for Uber Eats with the
beckhams obsessed I thought it was 10
out of 10 perfectly executed I loved
that they let her wear her Victoria
Beckham shirt that she sells people are
mad it's like $100 because it's
literally like a piece of merch um
obsessed uh what did they call her not
Jennifer Aniston Jessica
Jessica it's a funny commercial it is
and I'm sure we get like more commercial
at the Super Bowl for sure yeah all the
Super Bowl commercials are rolling out
slowly I also know that Edward was like
a a close friend of Taylor Swift so I'm
sure she's busy and she just couldn't
make it but it would have been cool if
she was in there it would have been it
was in December so she was free she was
free and it was in New York do you think
anyone got this email and like
didn't Taylor Swift you think um I could
see like someone getting this and not
realizing how iconic it was going to be
and just kind of being like oh they
wanted me to do some like celebratory
thing for British I I can't make it no
but like Oprah's there you know yeah but
then when you see the picture it's like
if anybody didn't participate who was
invited like you're you know what you
know who I actually think probably did
that Madison Beer she was supposed to be
in the video but yeah I love that
reference I'm
sorry cuz like that would happen to me
no know what would happen to me is like
to get an email and like not really
register the significance of it and be
like oh I don't really want to do that
and then you see the picture and you're
like I should have done that right
things I should have done that things I
didn't do that right so yeah Hugh James
Salma H Linda Evangelista they had a
sleepover the night before the article
said Salma stayed at Linda's place oh
not all of the women just Sal these two
but likeit why you saying Salma
Selma sorry wait who are we talking
about Salma oh sorry I thought you were
talking about Selma Blair is on there
too Blair is there too sorry I like
wasn't listening to you Sal mahek and
who Linda Evangel had asleep over that's
weird and isn't Sal mahek married to
that guy the like richest man in the
world yeah like she stayed at Linda's
place in New York like you can't get him
she stayed at Linda's
dump like that's a little weird for sure
that's like Elon too he's the richest
man in the world and whenever he travels
he stays at a friend's place and the way
that just would never ever be me like
not in a million years couch Surfer it's
so crazy and the way I travel I act like
I have Elon musk's Finance like imagine
if I actually did yeah just would never
be me you know guys know how I feel
about that like rich people cosplaying
as poor people I you know marry you with
paper rings type of things like no don't
don't Kate Moss on the cover with L moss
another Duo yeah cute it was it was
really beautifully done and it was
1,000% giving Jenna rank
yeah yeah and everyone looks great
individually and together like it
probably took a lot of styling yeah so
great execution mhm bonvoyage Edward I
didn't even know he was leaving yeah are
you ready for our next story yeah
podcaster Bobby Alto calls her strange
husband Corey incredible after he files
from for divorce from her no I need and
I know people tune into this podcast to
hear us explain stuff I need someone to
explain to me what the hell is going on
okay so Bobby ala for those of you who
don't know she is the one who had that
Viral podcast interview with Drake her
show is
called she was the girl who like she was
like a mom on Tik Tok who had like a
show called decently big platform she
started a podcast and literally it took
over the world people thought she was an
industry plant she had guests like Mark
Cuban Drake like it was so weird it was
so Random it was like a it was overnight
overnight and then it was gone and then
there were at the time like rumors about
her husband and rumors about like her
like sleeping with Drake like it was
just so crazy and I was like okay
whatever but then now they actually are
getting divorced so now I'm like wait
what the [__] yeah her podcast is called
the really good podcast and months ago
there were rumors that she like hooked
up with Drake after their viral
interview or whatever she totally denied
and she went on BFF's pod and there was
yeah that drama with Dave but now her
and her husband are getting divorced she
posted as most of you have heard Corey
and I have filed for divorce as sad as I
am right now I'm so thankful for the
time I got to be his wife our girls are
so lucky to have him as a father and I'm
so lucky to be able to co-parent with
such an incredible father in person now
I don't know anything and I'm not saying
that she cheated on her man but if she
did this would be the type of caption
you would write when you're really sorry
you know it's like a really nice caption
yeah like I [__] up he's good amazing
perfect man perfect husband anyone's
lucky to him like all right calm down
don't be mad at me please right like sry
y cuz when you write when you feel this
way about someone that like you would
write these nice things about them like
you should be married to
them right and why aren you you're a
great man you're a great parent like
okay so stay married totally random
totally like random sidebar so you know
Toby Keith the um country singer he
passed away from stomach cancer so sad
yeah I and I'm sure he was just you know
like really upset about it but like Luke
Holmes posted on his story like rip Toby
just that like legend or something but
it was like it was really short and what
was a picture of nothing just black
black rip Toby yeah it was all caps are
capital I capital P not so it was more
like rip Toby not rip Toby which is
better it's still a rip I know and I
think you know Luke was probably just
like acting out of grief and and I can't
be mad but like I just I wanted to note
that our King our King ripped you wanted
to rip him a new one no I didn't also
should we talk about the
backlash we didn't do we got a lot of
backlash for not choosing Toby Keith As
a story because like we're big country
music fans um and Jackie and I have said
this repeatedly and we actually spoke
about it offline like I we unless it's
like you know Queen Elizabeth dying like
I really don't like like talking about
death as a story it's like not
interesting conversation cuz what else
are we going to say like happy someone
di no like it's sad cludia we're going
to say rip yeah no and it's especi when
it's not like um a shock
like there are some that are stories cuz
it's like oh my gosh but you know when
it's just like rest in peace great
talent Legend and it's not someone that
we've really spoken about there's not
that much to say that's why it wasn't a
story but we have the utmost respect for
Toby Keith and we hope Jackson as well
we hope that he rests in peace Legend
icon like Red Solo
Cup I pick you up let's have a
party like thanks for clearing that up
it's not a big conspiracy you guys like
we just didn't choose a story yeah cuz
it's just I'm not going to say what I
was going to say it would have been a
pun oh that wasn't like it wasn't
intentionally be a pun but it it would
sound like a pun you know what I mean so
good you caught it so good I caught it
are you ready for our next story no I
kind of love the name
Toby
for people girl or boy boy okay Toby
Sofer on wait kind of love so cute it is
right I feel like Toby is always a kid
like a grown Toby I also do feel like
for a man like I don't know if I've ever
like met like a Toby who was in really
good shape like Toby is a fat boy's name
like 10,000% one letter away from
tubby also because it look like it
sounds and looks like tuba which is like
this huge instrument that's what I
thought think of oh I think of tubby
yeah tubby no for sure maybe it's like a
curse of a name especially with like my
jeans and Ben's jeans never mind but
maybe he was meant to be a
Toby I don't know I just kind of like
the name I also like the name Keith by
the
way people with last names that are
first names firsty lasty that's not a
firsty lasty okay there is a lot of
controversy and conversation about what
a firsty lasty is some people think a
firsty lasty is someone who has a first
name for a first and last name like Toby
Keith is a first name a firsty lasty
because no no we don't think that but
then other people say that being a
firsty lasty means like you're the type
of person who you can't just say Jackie
like it's Jackie asra you have to say
the first and the last name it's the
first last I'm not a firsty lasty no no
but I was using you as like an who's an
example of a firsty lasty like honestly
like Drew Barrymore like no one would
say drew right except her show is like
oh no it's a Drew Barrymore show right
cuz she's a firsty lasty yeah that's a
firsty lasty shout off in the comments
what do you think a firsty lasty is or
have you never heard that phrase before
is that an a family thing now no I feel
like it's from The Click
books it's giving click books it's
giving idiotic clickbook yes so I feel
like we can determine what the
definition is it's in writing it's in
the text it's in the scripture we can go
to the source should we reread the click
books no I think it would just like make
us like feel really like old and be like
what were we reading yeah like no wonder
like I was such a nasty little child
like I was reading the click books like
and who did I idolize in the click books
like the meanest [__] of all yeah of
course she was the best she was like the
prettiest the richest like of course we
were G to stand most stylish like
everyone wanted to be at massie's house
what is Massie doing this weekend Oh can
we get invited to massie's BBQ you know
the way she had her in and out L she was
doing it before 2024 right like no
wonder like girls our age like we we
grew up like watching Mean Girls and
reading the clicks like no wonder if we
nasty nasty women Gossip
Girl the books too that's what we read
th%
yeah now are you ready for our next
story what number is it it's number four
yeah so New York City was blessed with a
rare sister sighting on Tuesday and it
wasn't us no it was the Olsen sisters
Ashley Mary Kate and Elizabeth stepped
out for a sister's night out as
photographers captured the trio
strolling the streets while braving the
chilly weather oh I need to see these
photos I can't believe I always forget
that third one's related to them I know
and I just feel like they must be
distant because we don't see them
together but they're not and they are
together and they literally their
clothing line after her Elizabeth and
James oh my God by the way seeing them
all together is so crazy cuz Elizabeth
also does that like
smile no they're twins literally can you
tell Mary Kate and Ashley apart yes can
you no also did you know that Ashley
welcomed a baby secretly last year no a
baby boy named Otto wellow seeing them
all three just like being regular girls
walking around and now this article has
has photos of them like together
throughout the years there aren't a lot
yeah it's the craziest thing also how
the Elizabeth the youngest one like
Towers over them she's a giant well
she's not a giant she's probably like
Margo's height and they're our height h
i just like love them love like and
they're
so is so impressive I feel like not
enough people talk about the row enough
as it pertains to Mary K and Ashley
people know the row is like this like
you know amazing fashioned house but
like I think a lot of people don't even
put together that it's Mary Kan and
Ashley we just need like more from them
and I know they don't want to give us
anything but like just something please
a documentary a memo like we need you
the culture needs you I guess they're
giving us clothes and they like what I
want from them Inspire the generation
and our leading by example with their
fashion statements but we still need
more I don't know if I want a memoir
really I don't like I'm trying to think
format wise I mean if they did do a
memoir first of all we need a title
second of all would it be one book right
I feel like at they're 37 years old like
they want their own book yeah it's like
so so crazy they're only
37 wait is it wait they're 37 yeah how
on God's green diddly D earth does that
make sense
like which part they're too old or Too
Young Too Old not that they're too old
you know what me like they they were
always like a couple years older than us
no no I feel like when we were like
watching Full House and stuff they were
like younger than us no when we were
watching like their teen movies they
were like cool older no you're right
you're right like New York minute we
were like in the eighth grade and they
were like in high school yeah yeah yeah
okay okay that's fair yeah and and I
love that sister how old is Elizabeth oh
she's 34 and what about
James brother like what about him what
does he do I think he does brother Tings
James I think he does brother for sale I
think they sold him 25 cents brother for
sale he's not a big expense
JY well there's a lot of siblings
there's Mary kid and Ashley and
Elizabeth there is um Jake
Courtney I Trent
Courtney Chucky Chuy wait I don't
see James oh Jake I guess that would be
his birth
name
Courtney who is
Courtney Courtney Taylor Olsen is an
American actress she is popularly known
as the half sister of the Olsson sisters
Elizabeth and Mary Kate Courtney
Elizabeth is an actress yeah yeah yeah
Courtney half so there's there's there's
also
Trent must be another half if he didn't
get named on the label sorry older
brother no
he has played himself in a few of his
sisters video series he's brother for
sale I guess brother for sale only 50
cents what a tangled web that these
siblings weave now I want know about the
parents these parents who had like six
children two of them being such
successful child stars so the dad David
and the Stepmom so there are five
children some step I believe
cool yeah this is very very interesting
to me like I said documentary Memoirs of
an olssen and when the Olsen's got their
Hollywood Walk of Fame
star they brought all their siblings I'm
like on this gy image search right now
very
interesting so they had an SN last night
I love that I want to know where they
went I was going to say where did they
go SN inspo
right cuz where they would go like we
would go that's probably a good place
that's good for sisters and would F like
sisterly dialogue sisterly
love th% sisterly
closeness love so we'll have to make a
reservation before we dive into the
fifth and final story might I say
something always today's episode of the
toast is brought to you by Mattress Firm
the right mattress matters and Mattress
Firm will help you find the right one so
uh mattress is the most important in
your life and I dare you to take it
seriously because once you do your life
will be changed no more tossing and
turning sleepless nights like your bed
is
your for me it's a beacon of restoration
and peace and Mattress Firm where my
mattress is from yeah I was like a
little bit ahead of the trends I got it
like six years ago um it's actually my
second mattress in a row from Mattress
Firm from two different brands but both
from Mattress Firm and I bought them
both during their amazing sales they
have a lot of great sales every year um
and Shop the President's Day Sale it's
uh happening in store it's happening
online at mattressfirm.com
if you see a lower price Mattress Firm
will match it for you so they're
matching retailers prices get the right
bed now and if a better price comes
along they will match it restrictions do
apply Mattress Firm has quality
mattresses at every price for your best
rest so my uh mattress is currently from
tempor Pedic if you're looking for um
different price points they have all
different price points of mattresses
they also have different you know
bedding accessories so you can really
get everything top to bottom there they
also have the mattresses in a box a lot
of people love box mattresses they sell
them at Mattress Firm too and they offer
free and fast delivery to your door so
if you can't wait to sleep great get
free and fast delivery with Mattress
Firm Thrive this winter and save on the
sleep that you need there's a million
reasons why sleep can impact your health
and if you're a mom you're a working
woman there's just a lot of reasons you
need good good sleep so check out the
President Day Sale you can shop it in
store online at mattressfirm.com today's
episode is also brought to you by
vegamore real change happens when you're
consistent and achieving the hair of
your dreams is no exception thanks to
vegamore sticking to our hair care
routine has never been easier and we are
seeing the results that we've always
wanted vegamore products are 100%
crueltyfree And they are never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones so
Jackie and I both came to vegamore for
different reasons Jackie was entering
her clean era you know Mama hood and I
was looking for my hair to stop shedding
and everyone recommended uh a lot of
topical treatments from vegamore and
then it also happened to be this like
clean Beauty brand that Jackie loved and
we both fell in love with the grow kit
which is what I used to help a lot of
the the shedding that I was experiencing
after losing a lot of weight so the
thing about Vore is you have to be
consistent so the gross serum which I do
a couple times a week I love it does not
make my hair oily so I don't have to use
it and then take a shower and wash my
hair which I love um it also comes with
the shampoo and conditioner which is
fabulous clean products great for your
hair great if you're looking to keep
your hair full and healthy and you know
get on that gr that grow that grow [__]
um when you sign up for a monthly
subscription you can get one bottle or
three bottles scent you're going to save
more and you never run low on the
products that you need to take care of
your hair vegamore sells one bottle of
grow hair serum every 15 seconds on
their website that's how good this stuff
is actually just went to Sephora um and
the sales associate was like this is
like the hottest selling thing in here
I'm like girl I already have it like use
Co toast elevate your hair Wellness
routine this year with vegamore for a
limited time get 20% off your first
subscription by going to vore.com toast
and using Code toast at checkout that's
v g m o r.com toast code toast to save
20% off your first order vore.com toast
code toast thank you FAL la la la you're
welcome J our fifth and final story a
little Disney news because Moana 2 is
set at Disney with a surprise 2024
release date the line where the sky
meets the sea is calling Moana once
again Disney announced a sequel to Moana
will be released theatrically on
November
27th that's very exciting the second
Moana was originally developed veloped
as a TV series but became a feature film
because Bob Iger was impressed with the
footage so Moana 2 comes to theaters
this November also Moana is getting like
the liveaction treatment so there's just
like a lot going on in the world of
Moana and let me tell you another part
of this story that I find so interesting
I feel like I told you the story do you
remember I think it was during covid
when those two girls on Tik Tok um one
of them is like a pop star singer
songwriter the other is like this
musical composer um they started making
all these videos like what if Bridgerton
was Musical and they ended up writing a
whole album that got like millions of
streams that got nominated for a Grammy
and won it was like this amazing thing
that happened on Tik Tok um they have
been tapped to write the music for Moana
too oh that's so great which does mean
Lyn Manuel Miranda's out of a job which
people are both celebrating but also
being like but he did slap the first
time like yeah I feel two ways because
obviously like I don't ever want someone
to not have a job but ly menwell has
many so let's open up the field to other
people but he as much as we clown on
Lynn like he's responsible for so many
hits hit after hit and like how far I'll
go and you're welcome I mean if not men
well we wouldn't have Yad welcome what
say except y welcome we love to joke but
like at the end of the day like we
always say the cream Rises and that [__]
that soundtrack from Moana one like was
that [__] like it was top tier Lynn is
the cream question mark Jack cream
exclamation point Lynn is cream period
that's kind of like something for me to
wrap my head around like I don't
appreciate Lyn Manuel in his time no and
it's because like his personality gets
in the way of his talent yeah but I feel
again is that even true do we even know
him that Lynn is appreciated in his time
like everyone is obsessed with him he
gets every job that's remotely ly like
Lynn is a multi multimillionaire like
Lyn is # Lin is fine yeah but this is a
lot of pressure for those girls because
one a sequel is a lot of pressure even
if Lyn were doing it he has to outlin
the Lin Disney has a very high bar but
like if these songs like what oh no I
just got confused for a second but still
how far I'll go major yeah but I like I
I follow have followed this like these
two girls stories just because I thought
it was so cool that they won a Grammy
and I feel like they literally could win
an Oscar now or like a a golden glub
like they could be egots and they're
just you know two girls two girls
Abigail Barlo and Emily Bear yeah yeah
and they they're they call they're like
a writing Duo Barlo and bear it's giving
like pic and Paul you know pic and Paul
like it's giving iconic writing Duo yeah
I'd rather see pic and Paul out there
shaking that thing I wouldn't mind it I
I love me some pasic and Paul me too
except what's crazy is pasic and Paul
did La La
Land and I don't give a rip about La La
Land I didn't like La La Land maybe I
should should probably like watch it
again but I still not give a rip I just
don't give a rip no I know and when
people think pic and Paul they think La
La Land we think pic and Paul greatest
showmen or Evan Hansen
yeah huh La La Land that's like I feel
like that's like a glitch in my matrix
it's like something I should like that I
don't like there's a couple things like
such a good point it's such a good point
yeah I guess I just can't be pinned down
you can't put me in a box well that's
for damn sure you can't like make a
movie for me and expect me to like it
you just but I am going to pin you down
right now because the girlies need your
help Jackie it's deer toaster time so
sit down and help I should do so deer
toasters is our weekly advice segment
where you guys write into us and we'll
choose three submissions every week to
try and help out the girlies all the
issues they range from you know wedding
stuff to work stuff to health stuff to
husband stuff mostly um so feel free to
write Us in dear toasters gmail.com is
the email your prompt will remain
completely onon us if you've written it
and we have not read it on air either
your prompt is uninteresting or it was
too long try and keep it like concise
need to know information you can also
head to the toast podcast.com check it
out there there's a little submission
box once you scroll down on the website
also Anonymous ready yep good morning to
the wonderful stunning tury and the
Beautiful wise Jacko I am writing in
because I am having a predicament my
hilarious husband has recently started
doing stand-up comedy and is starting to
climb the comedy ladder where we live
when he first started doing comedy I
told him that I didn't want him to joke
about me during his sets because I
didn't want to feel disrespected now
he's getting invited to host shows and
when I go to his shows that feature
other Comics I've noticed that every
single comic but my husband tirelessly
jokes about their wives significant
others during their sets am I being an
insecure loser should I just let him
joke about me to help his comedy career
tury have you had this combo with Ben
help that's such a great question and an
interesting predicament and I I feel
like you're being very self-aware but I
think the boundary that you said is
really nice and if I were you I wouldn't
reconsider it unless he comes to you and
says like listen I have this joke and
having this boundary is like holding me
back a little bit or having him you
approve a joke I would just like wait
till he mentions it but if he's having
success not joking about his
relationship I think that's like really
respectable and totally
fine that's so funny I was going to say
something different even though like I
do agree with you the thing is is like I
do feel like it's most likely limiting
his potential because so much of Comedy
is like about your own life and if
obviously you're married like a huge
part of your life is your marriage
there's so much to be a better comedian
because if everybody's making
relationship jokes and like he has to
think outside of that box like he might
eventually be like one of a kind in
making different kinds of jokes it's
possible I I I guess I wouldn't you know
say anything unless he says something
yeah and it's very sweet that he hasn't
um I never ran it by Ben but I also know
there's a line like I'm not looking to
be out here embarrassing my husband like
I want to do a show that's like
relatable and funny and that people can
relate to but also like I have a norm
I'm not the type of person who that I
have respect for my husband so as long
as your partner loves you and has
respect for you they really they won't
say something awful you know yeah even
in the name of a joke yeah I think that
if it's Weighing on you you could ask
him and be like hey is this kind of
holding you back do you ever wish that
you could make these jokes and you guys
could have a convers about it you don't
even have to like wait for him to bring
it up cuz maybe he doesn't bring it up
because he knows that you would say no
so I think you should broach the subject
and ask him see how he feels about it
and if this is something he's been
feeling like oh I have these jokes like
maybe you guys could start somewhere
where like he just like runs them by you
and not forever but just to get you
comfortable with it I think that like I
I think it's awesome that he's gotten so
far while respecting your boundaries but
if you're starting to feel like you're
holding him back then just ask him about
it yeah I think this is is nice yeah you
both sound like normal level-headed
people who can have a conversation which
is amazing isn't always the case with
your toasters or
comedians
fact was that a Bert Cher dick no I'm
kidding all right you ready for our next
one yeah hey Jackson tur this one sounds
like a novel like a thriller my maternal
grandmother called me yesterday for a
very casual conversation but towards the
end she mentioned that she and my
grandfather were going to get their Will
Made later this week she explained that
their cumulative assets total over $4
million and that the inheritance would
be split between my younger sibling and
I this was completely unexpected she
told me not to tell anyone besides my
boyfriend I know this will be so awkward
when the time comes and my mom finds out
both she and my dad will be shocked and
hurt she encouraged me to be transparent
with my boyfriend we've been together
for over 5 years lived together and plan
to get engaged within the year can I
make him promise not to tell anyone I
don't really want his family to know
what do I tell who do I tell what do I
buy do I need a lawyer this is so weird
Granny's causing drama not even fact
that she wants to give it to you guys
which is you know her right to do but
that she wants you to tell your
boyfriend doesn't want you to tell your
mom like why is she playing games this
Grammy whatever you do do not tell your
boyfriend like sorry I like to me we'll
get into your mom in a second CU that's
[__] awkward and like you'll have to
figure out whatever but like literally
don't tell your boyfriend like I think
you can like keep this close to the best
I don't think you need a lawyer yeah and
even if she wants to leave the money to
you why is she telling you now and
causing drama between you and your mom
like Granny's causing trouble it would
have been better for her to just like
you know when the time comes like pass
away and then like mic drop with the
with the reading of the will very you
know very Gossip Girl um but she's like
putting this thing between you and your
mom By One The Inheritance and two like
the secret of
it what's granny up to yeah and also
like is your mom like waiting on this
money
like yeah I
just
I like to respect yach elders and
typically if there's a grandma like in a
deer toaster I'm always going to take
Granny's side but like what's granny got
up her sleeve yeah there was kind of no
reason for her to drop this bomb like it
should have been poisly also why she's
only doing her will now people have
Wills like throughout their lives yeah
maybe she's rejiggering it because she's
like having an
argument with her daughter and she's
like trying to get you on her side by
giving you two M right right right
granny is being Betty do not tell your
boyfriend like I feel like that's the
more important part of this conversation
let it be like a nice thing once you
guys get married like then you really
can share but like this is private and
boyfriends I'm sorry they come and go I
know' been together for 5 years y y no
the money isn't yours yet even so
there's nothing to say she could blow it
all before she goes she does sound also
like a little bit like a reckless kind
of woman like maybe she changed changed
her mind she's giving Reckless granny I
would didn't count this money as your
own just yet it's so true maybe just sit
quiet and it's nice I guess the only
person you can really talk to is your
sister yeah so kind of the you talk to
your sister I wonder if granny told her
something different I think Granny's
playing games or did granny not even
tell the other sister it's giving like
um what's that movie Knives
Out
yes it's giving nice out like everyone
thinks they're getting the inheritance
oh my God and Granny wants to see what
they all do keep it to yourself and
someone's GNA kill
Granny don't play this game I wouldn't
get caught up in it I agree it's a trap
it's a trap go about your life as if
granny never told you because you're not
getting that money I'm sorry to tell you
yeah it's giving diabolical
Granny it's giving diabolical granny our
third and final deer toaster is looking
for a little bit more of um like
tactical advice okay I love tactical I
love I think we can actually
advice I've heard thisable I've heard
this marriage chip recently that when
like uh your partner is complaining that
you should say do you want Comfort or do
you want
Solutions and I feel like that's what
you would say to like a kid no no it's
like when you're complaining about
actually wait I love that right when
you're complaining about something like
do you want me to actually tell like
help you or just like commiserate with
you oh my God that happened to me the
other day like
I oh my God Ben was oh my God cuz I go
straight for Solutions I'm solution
oriented which is why I like this dear
toaster that's why I brought this up but
it's a great question to ask you want
Comfort or you want Solutions oh my God
because no Ben was coming at me with
Solutions and it felt like an attack
like like I like I was doing something
wrong and that's why I was in this
position and honestly like I got so mad
at him and I was so wrong and I took my
anger out on him because I was angry
about something else oh my God I love
that can you like text that to Ben yeah
oh yeah I I was thinking like I need it
that's so funny I think Ben and I are
really
similar are we yeah Ben definitely like
takes on in terms of like emotions like
sometimes a little bit more of like the
traditionally feminine role like he's
very emotional no I'm not emotional like
if any you're not yeah yeah I don't know
anyways I just thought it was um it was
good cuz also when you just want comfort
you don't want Solutions my friends no
no it's like stop and I'm always and it
also forces a person who's who's
struggling to be like what do I want you
know to yeah be like huh that's a good
question it's good
marriage tip of the day so speaking of
actionable advice I am a 30-some mother
of Two And since having children I feel
as if my vocabulary is embarrassing and
limited I find myself struggling for
simple words and synonyms in my
workplace I was an advertising and
marketing major in college and my
written communication far exceeds my
verbal mostly because I have time to
compose my words I'm worried when I
actually meet people for work they think
I am dumb you both have such a colorful
spoken vocabulary would you attribute it
to being Avid readers or something else
please help please be the share horror
what's to my tie I hope it's not
sporadically that is such a good
question I just have to say if I didn't
do this podcast every day that would be
me like my your brain it's so easy for
your brain to become mush like you're
talking baby talk all day like one word
and you're trying to find the simplest
word for what you're trying to convey to
your child so it's totally normal and
natural literally doing the show like
forces me to exercise my brain which I'm
grateful for but I do find it harder
these days than it used to be for me to
like reach words what was the word the
other day I couldn't find
recreationally yeah so this is so real
and I do feel like I have a very
colorful vocabulary but it's because I
practice every single day by doing this
show so I don't know if it's enough for
you to just listen to shows like this or
other shows where there's a lot of
colorful language because maybe you can
absorb some of it but reading of course
right no but she really said like she
has it's not so much her like knowledge
cuz she's like I can write really well
like she has the words she has a hard
time bringing them brain mouth you know
like connecting your brain to your mouth
and I feel like it kind of sounds like
she needs brain camp yeah but what is
brain camp in I don't know what is brain
camp I mean there are like a bunch of
apps and games like I play this game
it's a board game it's called anemia and
anemia like the definition of that word
is like when you H when you can't think
of like you know the word but you can't
say it it's like the the brain mouth
connection it's actually a really fun
game but I also think it's actually like
a challenge that would perhaps put you
on the spot so a board game yeah a board
game also I think maybe even just
calling a friend having more adult
conversations maybe a friend who's like
your funny Lively friend and it's just
going to be like an upbeat
conversation um that can help you just
like exercise your mouth you can
practice because when I go back and
listen to like old episodes of the toast
my God I sound so stupid I say sentences
like filled with nothing like um yeah
totally and I'm still not great but I
say much more substance in sentences now
yeah it's a skill that you have to like
fine-tune and when you spend so much
time talking to Children of course of
course it's so natural but yeah trying
to find more time for adult
conversation maybe a word of the day
I've never really stuck to a word of the
day but the few times I've done it like
I've gotten something out of it but I
don't know really where I get my new
words from we were having this
conversation when I did Shannon's
podcast she was asking about my
vocabulary like how do I have such a big
vast F vocabulary and I do not know the
answer reading definitely helps but I've
had it since before reading no but the
thing for me is like I have to see and
interact with a word like 10 times
before I start to even want to know what
it means like Mercurial is a new word of
mine and it's because it was in illicit
Affairs by Taylor Swift and like I was
like okay that's a word I just learned
that word then it started showing up in
books a lot and on my Kindle I would
like highlight it look at definition it
means like sort of like
unpredictable my serious if you will
um and words like I learn words like so
randomly like even one of my favorite
words
acrimonious I learned from
friends so like I just pick up words
randomly but it takes a lot for a word
to stick with me unless you start using
it all the time because then we sh we
word share yeah nefarious of Course Elk
classic that's a big one low no but
don't feel bad about this and it'll
it'll come back it comes and goes it's
hard it's a it's a it's a total life
change and also it's it's physical and
mental like you literally like it
happens whether or not you do start
talking baby talk like and it also
happens because you start talking baby
talk MH so go easy on yourself girly
swirly
go bab that's our show and tomorrow will
be our last one of the week and then
next week when we are back Jackie and I
will be together podcasting so exciting
fun times I realize that next week is a
short week because it's President's
Day on Monday that's not next week
that's the week after
next President's Day isn't like after
the Super Bowl it's the following week
so true true and of course you know
let's give everyone fair warning we will
be taking off President's Day of course
we respect the presidents I mean God
Bless
America you know
that I
love you know he stand beside her yeah
and guide
her through the light with the night
from
above I love that song they're all Bops
from also like this land is your land I
love all of those songs of the American
elk the elk yeah they're beautiful o
Banner like like the Betsy Ross Vibes
hits the hits start coming and they
don't stop coming chilling no and it's
like they were written a couple hundred
years ago and they still slay the house
down in Boots a song that I put in that
category that's like kind of not and
it's modern and like it has no semblance
but I just consider them all the same
type of song is and I'm proud to be an
American where at least I know I'm free
yeah the greenw slay the house down
boots also like this land is your
land this land is my land that's right
from
California all the way to the New York
island them Islands from the Redwood
Forest to the Gulf Stream
waterers this land was made for you and
me amen video it to you thank you guys
so much for listening to the toast M
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
stories you need to know every Monday
the Friday on YouTube so you're watching
us on YouTube please to subscribe this
video thumbs up also available as
pod beautiful set wly talented we are I
have a new
outro and it's the perfect way to end
the
episode okay where does it go is it are
we getting now it goes About Love You by
I can add it to the end okay how
wickedly talented we are without further
Ado we bid you a du love you bye I love
it SL the house down boots boots boots
boots